hi everyone welcome back so we've been
talking about extreme seeking control
and I thought it would be fun to try an
actual live demo where in real time I'm
going to show you how easy it is to cook
up an extreme MC controller in MATLAB
Simulink okay so for those of you who
don't know I'm gonna just click go on
Simulink and generate this blank
simulating canvas what Simulink is is
essentially a real-time environment in
MATLAB where you can simulate physical
systems you can simulate dynamical
systems you can design control laws kind
of with point-and-click block diagrams
so we've been drawing all of these block
diagrams from for control you can
directly implement those in Simulink
it's an extremely powerful environment
you can even simulate you know PDE use
or OD ease and control those in here you
can use simulation or interact with real
Hardware you can use these simulant
controllers to control a real physical
system in real time and you can watch
the output using virtual oscilloscopes
so Simulink is an awesome environment
very very powerful fun to kind of
sandbox and play around in and this is a
little dangerous but I really want to
try a live demo right now I'm just
dropping in all of this kind of extreme
seeking control architecture and showing
you how easy it is in real time to
design one of these things okay so we
fired up Simulink I'm gonna click on
this button here which is going to give
me my my library of stuff so if I click
on that I get my browser of all of my my
simulate blocks that I get to play with
and you can see here that there's a ton
of stuff ok so here's all the common
Simulink stuff but then there's you know
aerospace blockset there's like a neural
network toolbox there's all this stuff
that you can drag-and-drop into here and
build these pretty sophisticated
interactive interactive systems and one
of the things that's great about
Simulink is that matlab kind of
abstracts all of the time integration
and time stepping and error tolerances
for stiff systems and and so on so you
can kind of drag and drop and connect
all this up and it will figure out the
best way to simulate it to give you good
results
okay so the way I'm going to start this
is I'm just going to drop in all of the
blocks I'm going to need and then I'm
going to connect them up and we're going
to tune the extremum so you can
controller okay so what are we going to
need I'm going to need an integrator
gain a gain I'm going to need I'm gonna
have to inject a sine wave and add it to
my best estimate I'm also going to
inject that sine wave and multiply it by
my high-pass filter output so I'm going
to need this multiplication block right
here and this addition block okay I'm
gonna need my multiplier in addition I'm
gonna change the colors in a minute to
make this look a little cooler okay I'll
need some sinusoidal inputs so those are
in the sources so I'm going to go down
here and get my sinusoidal input block
I'm gonna need some virtual
oscilloscopes so I can plot the output
so let's take one of these virtual
oscilloscopes here okay that will be for
my objective function that I'm trying to
maximize maybe I want another one for
the input so I'm gonna have two
oscilloscopes one for the output one for
the inputs okay so what do I have I have
my second soda line' put my addition my
multiplication I have my oscilloscopes
okay I need an integrator a high-pass
filter and my objective function
integrator high pass filter objective
functions so okay for the continuous in
the continuous block I'm gonna pull this
integrator one over s so I'm going to
use an integrator block I'm also going
to make my high-pass filter out of this
transfer function block okay good
transfer function block and the last
thing I have to do is design my
objective function and I think that is
in user defined functions this f of U is
going to work just fine for us okay so
this is my output as a function of my
input u f of U okay and I think that's
actually all the building blocks I'm
going to need I have everything I need
so now what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to make this look a little bit
cooler so that you can see it better
at home I'm gonna make my foreground
color white and I'm gonna make my
background color black so that it pops
okay and now I'm gonna start actually
arranging these things and connecting
things up in the right topology okay so
let's do that let's let's just get the
course ordering here so I'm gonna have
some oscilloscopes to measure stuff I'm
gonna have my objective function here I
have my sine input down here I have a
high-pass filter integrator gain matrix
I'm gonna want to multiply some stuff I
guess and I'm going to want to add some
stuff and now notice that everything all
these arrows are pointing in this
direction but my feedback control is
going to go this way I'm just going to
flip some stuff so I'm just going to do
that really quickly rotate and flip
control I apparently flips it so I'm
gonna do that here here here and here
and delete that line because I don't
want that there and I'm gonna flip this
one too okay so we're pretty much ready
to build our our control topology our
extreme so you can control loop and so
this f of U is kind of given to us I
don't you know we're not gonna we're
gonna define what it is but but this is
just we have some measured output of our
objective we have some input that we can
use to change the system and we're gonna
wrap our controller around so let's
start with that let's map from here and
I think in Simulink it's about as easy
as just clicking on these arrows and
then dragging to where you want them to
be okay so now i've connected up the
output to my high-pass filter I'm also
going to connect up my oscilloscope so I
want to essentially measure I'm going to
measure the output of F in my
oscilloscope okay my high-pass filter
I'm going to multiply that by my sine
wave so I need to connect up my
high-pass filter to this multiplication
block I'm also going to connect up my
sine wave to that multiplication block
so here my sine wave gets multiplied by
my high pass filtered outputs I want to
bring everything a little bit closer
yeah I want everything a little bit
closer so I don't have to reach so far
okay this is my D modulated signal so I
take my high-pass filter output a
high-pass filter and I'm multiplied by
my sine wave and I get that signal
that's mostly positive when I'm to the
left of the optimum mostly negative when
I'm to the right of the optimum and I'm
gonna integrate that into my best
estimate of U so here's my integrator
block here and let's connect those up
now this integrator block normally I
would have some K over s some K constant
some gain I'm just to make it easier to
code up and the Simulink I have this
little triangle here which is kind of
the universal block diagram for a gain
so this is gonna be my integrator gain
and then I'm going to add my so that's
this right here let's see if I can write
hopefully on top of here so this right
here is U hat this is my best estimate
of my optimizing controller I've
integrated up the demodulated signal
I've multiplied it by some gain this is
my u hat and I'm going to add to that u
hat my sinusoidal perturbation from this
sign block okay so that's kind of one of
the last steps here is I'm going to
connect that guy up not as easy as it
looks on a touchscreen come on come on
come on come on let's just connect this
guy up to here good okay so now my
sinusoidal ripple is adding to the best
estimate U hat and then that that ripple
when I add the ripple that's actually
what's gonna go into my system F okay
this is not the prettiest control
diagram in the world I have to be honest
if I was doing this at home and not on a
touchscreen I'd make all these lines
straight and I'd bring it all together
but it's fine okay I also probably
wanted my second oscilloscope to measure
the input okay so I've got one
oscilloscope on the output one
oscilloscope on the input so I can kind
of simultaneously watch what's happening
with you and what's happening with J the
objective function
okay so that is basically it that's how
you build an extremum seeking controller
and Simulink it is super simple now
we're gonna actually populate this with
some values and I'm gonna walk you
through my logic of how you actually
tune one of these things and and what
variables you get to play with okay okay
so my function my objective function I'm
gonna try to use the same value that's
in the book and it's also in in the
other videos where we coded this up as a
script and I think that was 25 minus 5
minus u squared so this thing has a peak
when u equals 5 and that peak is at J my
objective function is 25 so at U equals
5 I have J equals 25 and then when I go
to the left or right this thing drops
off like a parabola so it's a very
simple static cost function okay in
general you can put a real OTE a
dynamical system differential equation
in here some X dot equals ax plus bu or
some X dot equals f of X this can be a
dynamical system again I'm just showing
you the simplest case with a static
objective function if this had dynamics
you'd have to consider what the
timescales of those dynamics are when
you design all of these other blocks
okay that would be very important but
here we have a static objective so it's
a little bit easier to design everything
okay let's hope I can do this trying to
just move everything over a little so I
don't have so much space to walk ok good
so we have our objective function so now
what are the actual parameters we get to
start with so I have to have an initial
condition for u hat I have to set have
some initial guess for what my best
optimizing controller is and so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to I'm going to
use this initial condition of my
integrator block so basically you hat
comes out of the integrator and in
Simulink that's where I get to choose an
initial condition for u hat and I'm
gonna start with u hat equals 0 because
that'll be sufficiently suboptimal that
we'll be able to see it converge to the
optimum ok good
what else do I get to do so I get to
change my let's say I have a sinusoidal
ripple so let's play around with this in
many physical systems this ripple is
actually a side effect of how you're
building your your system and so in the
case of in one case we tried to use
experience you can control to optimize
solar array performance and our DC to AC
converter gave us a ripple that we
couldn't really control and so
oftentimes the parameters of the
sinusoidal ripple are things that are
just given to you so I'm gonna I'm gonna
say that our amplitude is 0.2 and that
our frequency is 10 Hertz 10 times 2
times pi in some cases you actually
would get to increase or decrease this
amplitude and you might get to change
this frequency but I'm just going to
kind of lock these in in some cases you
can change the amplitude for example by
putting on a bigger or smaller capacitor
things like that so that actually was
one of the trade-offs in the solar array
design but for now we're assuming the
system is given to us and we have a
fixed ripple at a fixed frequency and
amplitude and so the actual knobs that
we get to turn are this gain matrix and
our high-pass filter frequency so those
are kind of the things that we get to
play around with in some cases you can
also play around with the amplitude and
frequency of this but for now let's say
those are locked ok I think we're ready
to go let's try let's try running this
and it's always a little dangerous to do
a live demo but I want to I want to be
as kind of transparent as possible about
how easy or difficult this is okay I ran
it it did some compiling it simulated it
and now it's ready to go so that means
it's finished so I can double click my
objective function that's terrible I
wonder that's so bad that I don't think
I think there must be something wrong
here what did I do wrong
oh my high-pass filter is actually a
low-pass filter I didn't design my
filter at all so ok my high pass filter
is supposed to be s over s plus Omega
naught Omega sorry I'm gonna get H
my high-pass filter frequency and in
MATLAB the way you can see that this is
a 1 over s plus 1 that's not an not an S
in the numerator so in MATLAB the way
that you define these transfer function
blocks are with numerator polynomial
coefficients and denominator polynomial
coefficients and so if my polynomial
only has one coefficient then it just
corresponds to the constant term 1 so if
I want to make this s plus 0 I do 1
space 0 and then my denominator is 1 s
plus 1 so this would be s plus 1 I hope
that was clear so now I have a proper
transfer function s over s plus 1 so I'm
choosing my high-pass filter cutoff at
and a frequency of 1 and we might change
that later depending on the performance
so let's just for now let's try to run
this ok good so you saw at least one bug
really really quickly I didn't design my
high-pass filter transfer function so
you always have to do that so let's run
it again
superfast double click is now I get
something much more reasonable my
objective function J starts at 0 because
it was 25 - it was a J was equal to 25
minus 5 minus u squared and I started at
U equals 0 so this J at that point was
25 minus 25 so I start at 0 down here
and you can see that my extreme seeking
controller this this block diagram is
actually working I am increasing my J
but I'm doing it a little slowly this is
not as fast as I want right this is
pretty a pretty slow rise and I'd like
it to be much more aggressive rise up to
the up to the peak ok so what do I
actually get to change in this system to
play around with to get this to to
converge faster well one thing I get to
do is I get to increase this integrator
gain here so let's let's bump this from
1 to 5 I hope that's not too aggressive
ok let's run that I got a ding hopefully
that means it worked ok cool this
actually looks
pretty good so now my J function is
rising at a pretty good clip when it's
far away and then it slowly tapers off
to nearly the optimum value of 25 with a
little ripple on top so this is already
doing much much better just by bumping
that gain K which is kind of my first
line of attack is I'm gonna get a rough
order of magnitude of what my gain K
should be so that I get kind of the
right behavior maybe we should also look
at the U signal so this is my my U it's
increasing but notice that it's actually
it's kind of slowing down before it gets
to 5 so it's gonna take a long time to
get all the way up to that optimal value
of U equals 5 but because this is a
quadratic cost function the output is
still pretty darn close to 25 so it's
still pretty good but it's not good
enough I want better performance okay so
what could I do I could try to bump my
my gain up higher I could try K equals
10 or K equals 20 let's try that let's
see what happens at K equals 20 okay
runs okay now I actually get like
ridiculously fast rise and almost 0
steady state error here because it gets
up to the peak value and then when when
u is at that optimizing value if it
swings to the left and the right
essentially my slope is flat in my
objective function so the objective
function doesn't dip at all
so just bumping up that gain did a great
job and gave me very very fast
performance let's look at what do you
does okay and I get this really fast
performance up to u equals 5 which is
the optimal value now a couple of things
that you know I've done a lot of extreme
so you can control so I've seen these
kinds of curves all the time there's
some things that concern me about this
really big gain K equals 21 is you can
see that this this is pretty phat here
and it's kind of this inconsistent it
gets really fat and then it gets really
really skinny something about this tells
me that this might be kind of getting
towards the edge of instability and
maybe if I added noise to my system or a
tiny little time delay or you know this
might be getting right on that margin of
instability so in a simulation it looks
awesome
but I'm a little worried about the way
that this looks so you might also in
this block diagram add a little bit of
noise disturbance teeny-tiny time delay
just to simulate what's more realistic
in a physical system so that you don't
tune this thing to be amazing in a noise
free clean simulation but then break in
the real world okay let me make this
more extreme if I make this fifty it's
probably gonna look pretty bad so let's
let's see what that looks like yeah so
now you can see how like jaggedy and
horrible this is you don't want your
extreme seeking controller to look like
this this is bad even though it kind of
works in simulation I would never trust
this in the real world okay so we're not
going to use that one we're gonna go
back down I think a gain of 10 is
actually pretty reasonable here
one thing I'm gonna do is I'm actually
going to change my high-pass filter a
little bit I'm gonna make my denominator
coefficients I hope this doesn't break
I'm going to increase the frequency of
my high-pass filter from 1 to 5 I'm
gonna make it a little bit more of an
aggressive filter and I'll tell you why
in a minute I hope I don't mess anything
up here and now this is kind of exactly
what I want this is what I want my
system to look like I have a pretty
consistent small perturbation I don't
have those fat you know oscillations in
the cost function I have a pretty small
band of oscillations tapering off to
nearly perfect performance in the
asymptotes and then if I look at what my
control signal does my control signal is
basically going right to you equals 5
and then hanging out there okay so what
did we do
we had a system given to us we had a
ripple given to us we didn't have that
much control over it but what we did
have control over was this gain matrix
and my high-pass filter so when I'm
designing an extreme seeking control if
I don't have access to this ripple I
can't change it
the first line of attack is I just run
it and I see what happens then I modify
my gain to get close and we kind of
realized pretty quickly that the 5 to 20
range was was kind of a good range 5 was
a little under aggressive 20 was a
little over-aggressive so I bumped it
down to 10 and then I tweaked my high
pass filter gay
to get just the right performance the
right performance and so the high-pass
filter gain is probably the most subtle
part of this this this high-pass filter
not not gain but the cutoff frequency is
the most subtle part of this
so this high-pass filter frequency in
this case five and it's probably five
radians per second I always get a little
confused about the units here but that
frequency of that transfer function
block is supposed to be designed to be
lower than the ripple frequency because
I want all of my ripple to pass through
I don't if I if my high-pass frequency
was too high then I would actually start
to attenuate the output ripple so this
output ripple is happening at ten Hertz
and if I made this 20 Hertz that output
ripple would start to get attenuated it
would start to get diminished by this
high-pass filter and it would be like
having an effectively smaller game here
so it would kind of defeat my gain here
by overly aggressively filtering out my
output ripple so that makes me want to
have my my lope my high-pass filter
lower than my ripple frequency but I
don't want to be arbitrarily low I don't
want it to be ridiculously low because
if my high-pass filter frequency is too
low that it's actually going to let some
of this fast rise through the signal so
this fast slope here if my if my
high-pass frequency cutoff is too low
then this fast rise will actually pass
through that high-pass filter block and
that can actually cause stability issues
it can cause this thing to like ramp up
into a runaway if enough of this gets
through then that can cause the system
to go unstable so that makes me want to
make my high-pass cutoff frequency
closer to the ripple and that's kind of
this tension you have in designing this
that's why I actually think designing
this is sometimes pretty challenging is
you want it to be lower than the ripple
frequency so you pass the ripple but you
want it to be higher than other
frequencies that occur in the system so
that you don't get these weird and
stabilities occurring and so if you're
actually designing one of these systems
and you're going for peak performance
and the system actually has dynamics and
time scales so this is a little bit more
complicated
I highly recommend you go back to the
original papers and books by Christic at
all because there's great kind of
analytical guarantees on when this will
and will not converge along with
guidelines for how to design these
things okay but you can see right away
how easy it is to design a really really
good extreme seeking controller and
Simulink so if you take away as I want
you to take away the first main one is
it's super easy and you should try it
it's fun you know I like just kind of
these these plug-and-play blocks you can
build really complicated interesting
control laws very quickly and easily and
it takes a lot of the simulation burden
off of you you just click go and it runs
so that's the first takeaway easy to
build an extreme so you can control law
in Simulink the second takeaway is that
this this architecture is very amenable
to analog control design so this is
supposed to be kind of simulating an
analog setup you can also simulate
digital setups and Simulink but the way
I've drawn it here this is all
continuous time and you could actually
build all of these blocks in analog
circuitry so you could you could get a
sine generator and an integrator and a
high pass filter and you could build
this entire extreme seeking control in
an analog circuit that you could then
kind of wrap around your system you
could kind of build this and clip it
onto your system and it would measure
the output and in continuous-time an
analog circuitry it would feedback this
this extreme of seeking control input
you and and control your system so
that's a big appeal of extremely seeking
control also is it's very amenable to
both analog and digital control design
so this is kind of supposed to be the
analog version that's why I had these
oscilloscopes up here I also have a
script where we show how to implement
this in digital or in discrete-time and
in that case I actually have to write
kind of a a for loop for every delta T
of my my digital controller and then
this this high pass filter becomes a
little bit more complicated but
basically the takeaway is it's easy to
implement in analog okay and the third
takeaway which I think is kind of
interesting doing this law
so I'm glad everything worked out and we
have a converging extremis II can
control I'm pretty happy with this this
output actually I think this is exactly
what I want my extremis you can control
output to look like no no wonder I mean
this was a very simple objective
function but the I guess the other thing
I you the third takeaway is just the
thought process of how you actually
build and tune these things so this is
given to you and you may or may not know
what its time scales are you may or may
not know a lot about your system so you
might have a lot of tuning to do because
this might have some time scales that
you have to kind of figure out the the
ripple may or may not be given to you
but basically if this is given to you
then the only knobs you really have are
this integrator gain and the high-pass
frequency filter cutoff and I always
start with the gain and then save the
frequency for for last so I get this
close you know I might take the input
frequency divided by 10 for this and
start there and then work on my gain
once I have the gain in a good place
then I'll work on my my high-pass
frequency if you actually have access to
your ripple then you have a lot more
knobs to turn you can change the
frequency you can change the amplitude
and all of those things will give you
faster or slower convergence with bigger
or smaller error and more or less
stability so there's a lot of knobs to
play with which is why in this demo I've
kind of kept it simple and we've only
played with K and Omega ok so I hope you
have the tools you need now to just try
this out on your own system I encourage
you to try some dynamical systems that
would be fun you know try your own
physical system you could even try this
you could build a little experiment that
you want to control you know a little
solar array or something like that and
you could get a you know some kind of a
digital to analog converter or A to D
converter and you could actually wrap
this around a physical system in
Simulink so there's a ton of powerful
stuff you can do here and I hope you
actually play around with with this
simple extreme seeking control loop okay
thank you